il faut pas trop de gibier il en faut
mais il faut le réguler le nouveau
directeur général de Chambord joue les
pédagogues c'est lui qui a initié
l'ouverture au public de ses comptages
de grands animaux d'habitude ces
opérations se font avec des
professionnels et quelques bénévoles
aguerris cette ouverture au néophyte
ravie les heureux bénéficiaires c'est
surtout que c'est en pleine nature et il
y a pas de grillage autour quoi non
c'est vraiment le naturel au grand mot
quoi toujours en fait aussi la notion de
patrimoine patrimoine naturelle que l'on
peut avoir grâce à ce type de comptage
Chambord c'est un bien national qui
appartient à tous qui appartient à la
nation qui appartient même à l'humanité
donc il faut qu'on s'entende tous partie
prenante donc oui je souhaite que chacun
sente cet appartenance à Chambord et en
effet peut-être sans doute en
fréquentant des lieux de Chambord qu'il
était moins jusqu'à présent
c'est 10 minutes en fait une image de ce
qu'on voit sur la prairie et on note les
espèces leur genre et leur classe d'âge
les invités du soir sont accueillis dans
les 35 observatoires du domaine
accompagnés d'un professionnel du
service chassé-forêt
à peine 30 minutes d'attente et déjà les
habitants du lieu viennent s'offrir au
regard ils sont en train de changer
les comptages de ce genre effectuent au
moins deux fois par an permettent
d'avoir une vision précise du patrimoine
phonique local
en essence alors ça c'est les programmes
scientifiques qui nous permettent
d'affiner cette population l'état de
cette population pour les sangliers
c'est beaucoup plus difficile
et beaucoup plus flucturant en fonction
des années puisque c'est lié un dimanche
à la fructification forestière
l'abondance de cette fracture
on estime qu'il y a un peu plus de 1000
sangliers mais la population double tous
les ans d'où l'impératif de réguler ses
grands animaux c'est nécessaire dans ce
domaine ceinturé de mur où la
surpopulation conduirait rapidement à
des épidémies ou à des problèmes
génétiques